Universal is the last Voyage of the
Demeter bombed at the box office after
it opened on August 11th so why did the
Dracula on a boat flake flop so hard
Demeter netted 6.5 million dollars on
its first weekend in theaters making
back just a fraction of its 45 million
budget perhaps the most immediate
culprit behind its lackluster financial
performance is its lukewarm reception
from Critics on Rotten Tomatoes the film
sits at 51 from professional reviewers
and is still unimpressive 74 from
audiences at large as of the making of
this video in his review for variety for
example Owen gleiberman wrote the last
Voyage of the Demeter is too explicit
too Dotty at rapid fire too much like
other horror films critics weren't
wholly unkind however Roger ebert.com
reviewer Peter sovchinski awarded it
three and a half stars out of a possible
four writing it's a smart well-made and
sometimes downright creepy take on the
tale that both four Buffs and regular
moviegoers can appreciate in equal
measure we call him Dracula but bad
reviews alone aren't typically enough to
keep viewers away from an otherwise
interesting release suggesting that at
least a couple other factors beyond just
its critical reception played a part in
the film's subpart box office Hall
before taking into account how reviewers
received a meter a multitude of factors
regarding its promotion and release made
its success an uphill battle prior even
to its theatrical Premiere Chief among
what might be considered marketing
failures is the fact that the film's
title doesn't accurately reflect its
biggest selling point the last Voyage of
the Demeter is technically a classic
Dracula movie adapting a chapter from
Bram Stoker's genre defining vampire
novel its title however simply evokes a
journey at Sea leaving casual viewers
unaware that it's actually a Dracula
story several International markets
feature distinctive names for the film
that take advantage of the name
recognition that Dracula has for example
in Australia the film is titled Dracula
Voyage of the Demeter a far more
inviting name that paints a clearer
picture as to what audiences can expect
Universal also decided to release a
horror movie in August a couple months
before spooky movie season officially
kicks off near the start of October not
only is this timing not ideal but it
falls squarely in the midst of
barberheimer mania during which theater
goers are still more likely to see
either of those two box office Giants
and an ill-timed horror movie that
bewilderingly buries the fact that it's
about fiction most iconic vampire so
cool while it's difficult to deny the
competition to meet her face from both
Barbie and Oppenheimer it should be
noted that the universal pitcher's flick
wasn't the only horror film competing
for the attention of audience members at
the multiplex during the Dracula films
opening weekend audiences had multiple
options to choose from during its debut
weekend to be interfaced competition for
both Disney's Haunted Mansion and a24's
talked to me they made 5.7 million
dollars and 5.1 million dollars
respectively almost in line with the
Dracula film 6.5 million dollar debut
when it came to that weekend's horror
offerings the trio definitely
cannibalized one another while Demeter
technically took the higher spot of the
three it's clear the crowded horror
landscape robbed the Dracula film of a
potential 10 million debut Haunted
Mansion appeals to both families and
teenagers thanks in part to its PG-13
rating seen as Demeter boasts an R
rating a portion of prospective viewers
likely went with Disney's Haunted
offering the R-rated talk to me
meanwhile is thriving thanks to positive
word of mouth and reviews Demeter was
the new film in cinemas but it was
arguably the least interest resting at
least from the audience's perspective
Payne Cinema goers gave the Dracula film
a B minus Cinema score signaling mixed a
negative word of mouth Haunted Mansion
and talk to me meanwhile boast B plus
Cinema scores perhaps the meter would
have shined earlier in the summer when
horror films were more scarce
even if International audiences were
interested in seeing the last Voyage of
the Demeter key markets weren't given
the opportunity to do so the film's
released in the United Kingdom has been
delayed indefinitely thanks to E1
shutting down operations in the country
with E1 now sold to Lionsgate Demeter
has lost their distributor in the UK may
God have mercy on us all only time will
tell if the universal project will
receive a theatrical release in the UK
seeing as how Demeter features a largely
Irish cast and with the majority of the
story dependent on UK locations it must
be difficult for Universal Pictures to
Bid Farewell to such a key territory
other International markets haven't
received the film as of yet slash film
reports that the flick is slated to
debut in Spain and India no official
release dates have been given with a
film bombing Stateside it remains to be
seen if Universal Pictures will move
forward with International releases or
cut their losses a few months before
Demeter premiered in theaters
Universal's previous vampire movie
renpeeled also bombed this was sort of a
canary in a coal mine foretelling its
successor's lack of box office success
Renfield Stars Nicholas holds his RM
Renfield a character straight out of
Bram Stoker's Dracula novel similarities
to its literary Source material pretty
much start and stop there however given
that Renfield is a quirky comedy set in
the present day audiences were
ultimately uninterested in this Twist on
the classic Dracula formula leaving its
total box office Hall short of even half
its budget that Demeter is on track to
Fair worse it's hardly surprising then
given how Renfield demonstrated that its
overarching formulas and something most
theater goers want to see and whereas
Renfield Stars big names like Holt
Aquafina and Nicholas Cage Demeter is
absent to Marquee star to make up for
its core concept failing to draw viewers
this phenomenon in fact extends past
just vampire movies both guy Richie's
King Arthur Legend Of The Sword and the
2018 Robin Hood film while not quite on
the same level failed to make back their
budgets as well further indicating that
audiences don't care about contemporary
spins on classic material as much as
Studio seem to think